[Music]
what if we said race isn't real
that it's an idea built by people that's
the subject of entertaining race
performing blackness in america the
latest book by best-selling author
michael eric dyson and it dyson explores
why we still entertain the idea of race
even though he says it doesn't exist he
also looks at how people including black
sports icons musicians politicians and
everyday americans all play a role in
shaping that identity in his own words
michael eric dyson shares how the early
ideas of being black in america were
born and what that means for today
on slave ships and plantations the
largest forced migration in world
history shaped the act of performance
into a tool of survival
and defiance in freedom
entertainment offered black artists a
measure of independence black people
forged a complex racial identity and
preserved ties to a cultural heritage
under relentless fire in america
whiteness is seen as inherently valid
while blacks must produce in each
generation fresh evidence of our
intelligence and humanity i can't
breathe contemporary black performance
carries the weight of this history
in both exceptional and everyday
expressions if you fall in love with
van gogh are the music of coldrain and
realize that that was created by a human
being just like you
no more human no less
michael eric dyson joins us right now
good morning how you doing good morning
it's good to be here good to see all of
you good to see you now let's jump right
into it in your title it's entertaining
race and you use this in two separate
ways right can you explain that i'm
hanging out with these rappers too much
you're getting these double and triple
on time
blame it on jay-z
first of all black people as i've said
from the very beginning have had to
entertain for white america that's on
the slave ship on the plantation sing us
a good song sing us a good negro
spiritual so we've had to entertain then
we've had to entertain the idea of race
whether we're uh our kids are selling
water or lemonade and somebody stops
them at starbucks we're we're asked to
perform and to entertain but we also
have to be entertaining about how we
speak about race it can't be the old
tried and true ways people come up with
new ways and challenges and we have to
be entertaining and we've been an
entertaining race louis armstrong uh
maya angelou oprah winfrey gayle king
these iconic figures and now nate
burlson joins them as well these iconic
figures who have had to perform
different roles different aspects lebron
james on the court lebron james off the
court he's a performer in both he's
shooting a jump shot but he's also
making sure that we get the right shot
at an opportunity in america that's what
we've got to talk about and that's what
i talk about in this book yeah but you
open the story with a very you open the
book with a very jarring story but 1792
right you said a white man of privilege
kills a for 15 year old girl because she
refused to entertain what is the point
you're making yeah i've never heard of
this story yes ma'am it's a remarkable
story and this young enslaved girl you
know had been infected with a venereal
disease by the doctor who examined her
because she was his prey he she gets on
board the captain you know dances the
slaves they often did that to keep him
in shape but also to titillate the white
uh
figures on board and she was sick and
couldn't do it she couldn't perform and
he whipped her hung her upside down one
leg with a lawn cloth on her and whipped
her to death and
it came out in court when they took him
to court for killing her and another
young lady that she refused to perform
that is a metaphor for black people we
have had to perform as if our lives
depended on it so yes we're smiling
we're grinning we're on stage but we
also have an internal life where we
nurture ideas and ambitions of democracy
and everything else that america wants
we want as well but we've been forced to
as paul lawrence dunbar said wear the
mask when you when you use this phrase
performing blackness you're not just
talking about black celebrities you're
talking about everyday black people in
everyday life oh especially every day
it's extraordinary with the you know
kobe's and the michael jordans and the
beyonces and the jay-z's but it's
everyday uh black people at their work
that's your hair is it real uh when you
go to work can i touch it can i touch it
or i'm in a corporate america you say
you're an ally you put a black space up
on instagram but internally you're
rejecting ideas of blackness so we've
got to perform deference but acceptance
but also resistance in a certain way so
yeah everyday you even said that george
floyd's death i mean i had to read that
twice that george floyd's death you said
was a performance absolutely
well what i meant he didn't mean so of
course but it was part of the
performance the pageantry of american
race in amer in this country so here's a
guy laying on the ground crying for his
mother asking for intervention saying i
can't breathe he's performing rituals of
black uh desire to be heard to breathe
freely and what we do we integrate that
into a larger drama the reason george
floyd struck universally across this
country and indeed across the world is
because people could identify with his
performance of deference and
vulnerability and not being angry and
yet asking for something basic and
primary is breath now michael we have to
go so i need you to be quick now
performing blackness it can be a great
thing right um what is your message to
those individuals that might be in the
sports space entertainment that have the
money that have the power of influence
but they don't use it to pass it forward
or help lift somebody up into the
position that they are in yeah remember
paul robeson remember jackie robinson
that's right remember hank aaron these
are figures uh uh you know althea gibson
who used their platform for a broader
reality because before you were a ball
player you were black before you were
entertainer you were black that
blackness bindings go black and you
steal black to this day but what do you
want us to do with this information oh i
want us to think about it i want us to
meditate on it and i want us to act on
it be more sensitive be more
understanding understand the roles that
people have to play and the roles that
white brothers and sisters and other
non-black people play we're all involved
in this shakespearean all the world's a
stage we're players on it and get
interested in our role get interested in
the history i mean americans love their
history right but not the controversial
aspects of it selectively we live in
what gorbad al called the united states
of amnesia so we like some stuff america
is obsessed with reproducing confederate
plays but when it comes to 1619 or
blackness or ideas ah not so much i'm
confused either you like history or you
don't like all of the history because we
all are part of america michael you are
the best i appreciate you thank you much
entertaining race is on sale now
it's 500 pages a lot to think about
this is cbs morning get your money's
worth